Before ending this lesson, I want
to talk about a couple of practical
considerations of particle filters,
and the first one involves sampling.
As you can imagine,
sampling is really important.
Okay?
Because I have this set of samples, and
every step I have to generate
a new set of samples.
So I have to re-sample it.
I go, grab a sample, where the
probability of pulling out that sample,
for its state x, is proportional
to the weight of that sample.
And typically, I'm doing this a constant
amount of times, so n times, so
I'm using 1,000 samples, 10,000, however
many samples, I'm doing that every time.
We'll talk actually not today but next
time, that number can get kind of big if
your state space gets large, so
being able to sample effectively or
efficiently, or less often,
is kind of important.
So I'll talk about
resampling a little bit.
What we have here is a,
an outer ring, okay,
where the idea is that the arc length of
that ring is proportional to the weight.
Okay, so, you know, w1 is small, w2 is
bigger, w3 is huge, etc., whatever.
And these are all the weights, right?
So you can think of sampling as
the following, I just randomly pick
a direction, and if I hit w3,
I'm going to take sample number three.
So that'd be my first sample.
All right, do it again!
If I hit wn,
I pull out the nth sample, and
basically I have to keep
doing that n times, right?
So, it's kind of,
it's like a roulette wheel.
I spin the roulette wheel n times, and
I have to figure out where I land, and
that figuring out is
actually a binary search, so
that's log n, but I do that n times.
So it's an n log n operation.
So that's kind of it's not awful,
but it doesn't
scale linearly with the number of, of
samples you use, it goes up by n log n.
It turns out there's a cute little
trick that you can use that is,
instead of like a roulette wheel,
is more like a wagon wheel, and
the way it works is this.
So let's suppose I have n samples.
I can make a set of spokes that
are 1 over n full rotation around.
So here I've got 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, right?
So each one is an eighth of an arc.
And what I can do is,
I can randomly put it down someplace,
and if I've randomly done it,
then I can just read off, for
each one of these spokes,
which w did it hit?
Okay?
And in fact, the starting way, right,
I can just start at some random one
here, and I see what w am I at, and
I go to the next one and
I see, did I pass a boundary?
If so, then I'm at the next w,
and likewise.
So, what's nice about that is
that's done in constant n time.
And it's sometimes called
stochastic universal sampling,
systematic resampling.
The nice thing about it is that
it's a linear time complexity.
You know if you do 10,000 points,
it takes you so long.
If you do 20,000 points, it takes
you just twice as long, all right?
And it's very easy to implement.
In fact so easy to implement,
let me show it to you.